alexander hat was sehr schön gemütlich
hier wie war dein tag ja was für ein tag
ist wieder wieder ein tag voller
interessanter und auch zum teil
verstörender nachrichten was war dein
höhepunkt heute für dich also mein
höhepunkt privat lieber privat als beruf
mein höhere unsere war meine frau hat
mir vorhin gesagt dass sie vier tage
weihnachtsurlaub gebucht hat jetzt ratet
mal wohin auf die malediven in den harz
sehr schön das ist kann auch sächsische
schweiz sehr empfehlen und das
voralpenland nein ich finde es
eigentlich ganz gut dass wir das wir
reisen wieder unser eigenes land den
decken sind eine folge eigene folge von
corona aber er weiß ob das überhaupt
stattfinden wird stichwort corona jens
spahn hat heute für aufsehen gesorgt als
gesagt hat am ende dieses winters werden
wir alle geimpft gewesen oder gestorben
ist dann glaube ich ja selber dazu
gesagt dass das natürlich zynisch
formuliert das ist es womöglich die wahl
also prognosen sind sehr schwierig ich
würde ich würde bei prognosen aufpassen
wenn der welt bin dann wenn eine so
drastische worte gewählt werden ich habe
so ein bisschen das gefühl
diese politik der angst stört mich ein
wenig ist schon wieder klima wie der
klimakrise wird und ständig angst gehabt
die gerät er sagt
und jetzt wird uns auch ständig an sohn
ist ja auch waren sie nicht dramatisch
es ist keine panikmache sie ist
dramatisch aber ich glaube trotzdem dass
angst das falsche mittel ist ich glaube
dass das auch die wenigen noch skeptiker
noch stuhrer werden lässt ich glaube
also ich habe einen anderen satz von
sparen auch heute in erinnerung der
sagte also um die knappheit des biontech
impfstoffes ging sagte er machte er
schon seltsam vergleichen sagte jetzt
alles schön das alles wunderbar freut
euch auf moderner und die fachleute
sagen mir moderner sei der rolls royce
und biontech sei der mercedes und ich
muss sagen ich fühle mich ein bisschen
unwohl wenn ich mit solchen kinder
vokabeln oder somit zu kinderbildern
abgefertigt weil er so wenn ich meine
wenn ich einen fünfjährigen das erklären
würde würde ich vielleicht ein ähnliches
bild ich bin erwachsen ich habe auch
gern die politiker wie erwachsenen
wollen würde eigentlich moderne an an
bringt aber rolls royce kann sich
keinerlei anderes zitat das heute die
runde gemacht hat war von lothar wieler
der hat einen satz gesagt da kommt ein
anderer in erinnerung mal gucken ob bei
dir weil er hat gesagt niemand möchte
gerne eine impfpflicht verhängen
sinngemäß also wenn ich so etwas höre
läuten bei mir alle alarmglocken der
erinnert natürlich du willst anspielen
auf den satz von walter ulbricht niemand
hat die absicht eine mauer zu errichten
und tatsächlich ist das ein weiterer
faktor denn ich glaube dass die menschen
verunsichert vor ich erinnere mich als
sparen im bundestag richtung afd sehr
streng
gepoltert hat und gesagt da hören sie
auf den menschen einzureden dass ist
eine impfpflicht geben wird es wird
keine impfpflicht geben und jetzt sind
wir in einer situation dass ganz offen
von allen spitzen politikern eigentlich
musst du selber auch vor allem auf
keinen fall ich bin ich bin dreifach
geimpft ich nehme auch gerne auch die
vierte und die fünfte mit ich habe ein
blindes vertrauen in die pharmaindustrie
aber warum denn eigentlich also eine
impfpflicht es ja nichts neues in
deutschland wir haben seit vergangenem
jahr beispielsweise eine masernimpfung
wurde übrigens eingeführt weil es jeden
500 fälle masernfälle jedes jahr gab
jetzt haben wir 30 tausend corona fälle
jeden tag warum sollen nicht da
logischerweise auch nicht eingeführt
werden
ich mag nicht wenn der staat mir die
dinge gefehlt das ist einfach so ein ur
ur
freiheitsdrang von mir ich mir ist dabei
unheimlich wo du hast recht und und ich
habe mich belehren lassen dass auch in
den 60er jahren gab es eine impfpflicht
und ich haben die ganze krankheiten ich
glaube es war kinder leben oder polio
komplett
ausgelöscht diese krankheiten
ausgerottet und du und ich wir haben ja
beide diese kleinen auch narben am arm
mir wurde da wusste ich als kind
natürlich auch nicht um meine eltern
auch nicht was da was dann geschieht ist
es ist war richtig also ich habe ein
grundvertrauen in die em die in die
pharmaindustrie und bin auch kein im
skeptiker aber ich bin bereit die recht
das recht von denen zu verteidigen die
skeptisch sind ja ja ich bin sicher es
ist ein thema das die gesellschaft
spaltet das bis in die familien hinein
geht wie sieht das bei euch in der
familie aus deiner schwester gloria
fürstin von thurn und taxis hat die ein
anderes fall dass dazu als wie
beispielsweise nein wir sind beide
durchgepustet und so weiter arbeiten in
der in der jüngeren generation darunter
sie tatsächlich anders aus oder gibt es
da gibt es auch durchaus so auch
streitigkeiten in der familie
mir ist das neu dass plötzlich man über
solche sachen streitet also aber meine
schwester erwähnst wir haben ja du hast
dir vorhin in der sendung über die
weihnachtsmärkte geredet in ganz bayern
sind die weihnachtsmärkte
geschlossen ein kleines gallisches dorf
leistet widerstand und zwar im
schlosshof von von regensburg
tatsächlich findet noch der
weihnachtsmarkt statt und nachdem es
auch komplett ab sperber ist und du
nicht rein kommst ohne geimpft und
getestet oder gewesen zu sein
verteidigt sich der veranstalter des
weihnachtsmarktes sehr und möchte das
weiter durchsetzen das wird jetzt vor
gericht wahrscheinlich enden aber es
gibt noch einen weihnachtsmarkt in
bayern der tatsächlich noch geöffneten
die lern regensburg jetzt zu dieser
stunde spricht gerade friedrich merz zu
den cdu-mitgliedern virtuell stellt sich
dort als kandidat vor friedrich merz ist
66 jahre alt und damit nur ein jünger
als die ein jahr jünger als die
scheidende bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
ist das die zukunft über die alt war
konrad adenauer als kanzler wurde ich
müsste mal nachschauen habe ich halte
sich über 80 oder ich mag nicht diese
modernen trend menschen zu
kategorisieren nach alter hautfarbe
geschlecht ist soll der cdu-vorsitzenden
werden am geeignetsten ist und ich finde
es auch schon ein bisschen seltsam dass
all die kandidaten ebenso wie so
feigenblätter alle mit frauen
generalsekretären daherkommen als ob sie
zum palm ist ja es hat so was jetzt hat
etwas sehr günstig ich habe komme sehr
gut mit frauen chefs zu recht aber alle
frauen chefs die ich ja sonst die frauen
kandidatin wir haben alles selbst die
ich als frauen hatte wurden deswegen
weil sie kompetenter bahn als ihre
männlichen
als ihre männlichen konkurrenten ich mag
nicht wenn jemand an land wird ob
deswegen alter oder oder oder oder
hautfarbe oder was auch immer das alter
ist mir wurscht ich frag mich ob er
dieser bekannten cdu wirklich neues
leben einhauchen kann also herzlichen
aber wo neues leben andere nachricht von
heute ampelkoalition kommt ist ein
richtiger
nachrichtenagentur ap wir machen den
nachrichtenüberblick hier wir beide
kommt zügig voran die ampel koalition
gehst du damit hoffnungen in die zukunft
freut sich drauf also ich freue mich
drauf ich habe heute gehört dass die
qualität koalitionsvertrag
praktisch fertig ist also wir hatten ja
immer gesagt
nikolaustag wird die koalition stehen
jetzt heißt es sogar dass schon bis
mitte nächster woche stehen könnte und
ja ich freue mich drauf also ich bin
kein grüner aber ich freue mich auch die
grünen mal in regierungsverantwortung zu
sehen ich mal sehen was sie wie sie
damit umgehen und gott dann gibt es ja
im bundesrat noch
eine kleine bremsfunktion um verrücktere
pläne aufzuhalten auf dem papier ist es
ja eine ganz gute kombination von allem
etwas dabei so die fdp kann so ein
bisschen von der cdu mit übernehmen
kontrollieren die grünen bringen
frischen wind rein die spd stabilität
und das soziale ja und ich habe das
gefühl dass die fdp sich ziemlich stark
aus diesen koalitionsverhandlungen
heraus gibt ich glaube in der zeit oder
wobei die überschrift herr linden
ergeben sie endlich zu dass sie ein
gangster sind
offenbar viele seiner vorstellungen
durchgesetzt müssen uns erst mal
erfreulich gleichzeitig sind auch schon
wieder viele enttäuscht von der ampel
aber lassen wir das mal aber sagt es
schon mal ins ausland die gute nachricht
kommt
von den royals die queen schon wieder
fit zu sein war bei der taufe ihrer ur
enkel dabei da kennt sich keiner so aus
wie du ja also die die die queen hat ist
glaube ich heute in meiner kolumne schon
eigentlich verwandt mit den windsors in
galaform ich nicht aber meine kinder
weil meine bei meiner frau verwandt ist
mit dem lg mit dem haus windsor und
deswegen sind meine kinder in der
thronfolge aber irgendwo aufstelle 6
zwischen 600 und 700 sie müssten sie
müssen so 600 leute um die ecke bringen
um eine realistische chance haben auf
den thron zu kommen also aber viele
werden sondern können bequem die queen
ist
biologisch 95 aber wenn man sie so sieht
ich glaube sie fühlt sich so als mit 70
jahren
und ich bin sicher dass sie sehr sehr
lange leben wird ihr ihre ihre mutter
wurde 101 und wenn sie bis 2024 aushält
wird sie tatsächlich der am längsten
regierende monarch in der geschichte
sein also bisher hält diesen rekord
posten hält louis kartons ludwig der
vierzehnte aber ich bin überzeugt die
königin hält noch bis 2024 auf und wird
dann für ewig in die geschichte an sich
aber auch immer so einen gin training
oder was hat die queen mum hatte er
leider verboten wird er wohl leider war
dann gerade im alter ist eigentlich dann
gefunkt sagt wann wenn ich jetzt schauen
wir noch auf ein thema heute morgen
umfrage hat mich doch erstaunt meinen
eine was heißt erstaunt eigentlich liegt
auf der hand eine mehrheit der deutschen
glaubt dass weihnachten sehr sehr teuer
wird die weihnachtsgeschenke sehr viel
teurer werden auch wegen der langen
lieferketten muss man eigentlich jetzt
schon
wegen der lieferengpässe muss man
eigentlich jetzt schon geschenke kaufen
was schenkst du deiner familie zu
weihnachten die frage möchte ich lieber
zurückgeben wenn ich versuche meine
meiner familie hat beizubringen dass
dieses jahr ein etwas bescheidenere
weihnachten wird ich möchte es gern sehr
festlich fein ein festliches abendessen
aber ich möchte zu diesem geschenke
terror so ein bisschen herunterfahren
ich habe einen sich die kinder wissen ja
ich hab ich habe würde gerne folgendem
trick einführen das ist hört sich es hat
sich sehr sparsam an aber es könne jeder
soll ein objekt das ihm selber gehört
dass er gern hat den nächsten schenken
das ist wichtig ja aber es nicht kaufen
sondern wirklich etwas was man was man
selber gern hat vielleicht ist auch nur
ein buch was ein oder ein schmuckstück
was man was man pech hat kriegt man das
was der andere loswerden er sollte
sollte die ich in mich ich liebe
festliche vor weihnachten aber ich leide
so ein bisschen unter diesem unter
diesem
weihnachtsgeschenk kommerz terror wie
sie es bei dir ich wünsche mir immer
große und teure beschränkungen kriegst
aber
es gibt die gelegenheit am freitag ist
ja der black friday und diese black
friday woche die ist mittlerweile ist
die beginnt jetzt und irgendwann gleich
bei uns in der sendung ein paar experten
da die die schnäppchen des tages und
dann auch der woche zeigen können dass
ziehen wir die ganze woche durch hat er
spricht dann auch einmal ein blech ist
doch was da wieder etwas klein das ist
ja schon mal entweder ein toaster oder
ein saugroboter
roboter sollte man ja so langsam in die
familie integrieren das ist ja ganz
modern ja übrigens habe ich heute gehört
auch noch eine nachricht von heute oben
auf der iss der unser deutscher
astronaut der da oben ist der hat ein
roboter der eben nicht nur sagt ob er
links oder rechts und kabel an löten
muss sondern eben auch witze erzählen 1
da so lang will ich auch haben einen
roboter der witze erzählen er das ist
fantastisch vielleicht sollte man das
bild auch einführen
in diesem sinne wir gehen wieder hoch
vielen dank für deinen persönlichen
nachrichten überblick alexander von
schönburg